hey everyone welcome back to another
episode of top 5 Skyrim mods of the week
I'm cam this is Sam Jose hello cam and
welcome to my side yes so my right side
how is that side of a table oh it's good
it's warm how's the right side of me oh
it's beautiful
good it is my better side so this is a
special episode of top folks going Roger
that except why is that well we figured
you know this game has a lot of dragons
in it it does no no it's 30 is almost
the crux of the game they really should
have put it in that first trailer yeah
they never did so we figured why not do
a mod special all about the Dragons what
are the best mods for the Dragons
[Music]
welcome sir ban Kevin to mod number 1
we're standing in the middle of the
plains by UQ cars monument you can code
but this is where we are said because we
need a nice open space for our first mod
absolutely and a first mod this week is
deadly dragons now if you go to the
Skyrim Nexus and you insert the word
dragon and search by most endorsed yes
you cannot miss this mod so Skyrim by
default has 7 very terrifying dragons in
it it does this mod adds 14 new dragon
types from level 10 all the way up to 65
that's amazing it also has an MCN menu
and this is my favorite thing about this
mod actually which we're gonna show off
is you can set dragon assault so you can
be like all right I want dragons to
attack me on the hour every hour and
they will you can be like I will one
dragon I want two dragons no way I want
three dragons to tap me otherwise it
doesn't work if you tick them all though
the top choice you can also choose
whether cities are safe zones so an
intact in cities yeah and unlevel oh yes
you can have it like say you're an early
game character and you want like the
ultimate dragons so they're not to be
skilled to your level you can set that
mmm let's just do that why the heck not
I want a big fight oh well gonna come
now ancient Nords used to hunt dragons
wits
I remember Wow oh now now you'll notice
there was a impact damage they said we
also have turned on a mod which we have
showcased before but you couldn't have
an ultimate dragon combination without
Jesus that's live yeah without this mod
on this mod is their ultimate dragon
combo overhaul what's wrong with Kevin's
body so we did we did dragon combat over
his perm at the beginning of this year
in fact episode 1 of 2014 so every time
the dragons lines we're getting thrown
about like a rag doll yeah I have three
dragons may have been a little much so
get up for the type of dragons so this
is down to it's a combination the mods
but this is down mainly to the deadly
dragons mod and this this ability to set
up the assaults is what I really love
cuz you can be like all right I want
epic battle now and you can call them in
and man this is a volcanic dragon he's
pretty hard and he's almost dead
actually
oh wait wait so one of the things that I
remember dragon combat overhaul does
yeah is when a when a dragon is is close
to death
you know it were tire for a minute and
let his oh yeah you can also kill them
out of the sky that's why I want to
leave that mod on because the killing
them out of this guy is like the curse
thing this is working well for you there
he is that's him it's got him
he's down are you still alive are you
dead I've no idea boys going on seeking
a long time to die said he's making a
real song and dance of it isn't he just
get it over with but look look at where
that there you are hahaha see this guy
is is trixie so the name of the this
dragon here dictates that that he is one
of the new 14 dragons react correct
correct and so did Dom by name I said
that was pretty epic but there's some
stuff we didn't cover in the MCM menu
here so we're going to deadly dragons
again
like misc you can affect a whole lot of
different things so you can set whether
you want npcs who are essential to be
able to die or not during battles you
can even convert this is an annual thing
your dragon souls into perks on-the-fly
that's different if there are mods that
just do that as a one-off yeah you set
the weight of Dragon Balls viable a
dragon skills so I've set them to zero
obviously good and finally said the
other thing can do the Dragons menu is
basically customize how powerful your
dragons are that you can only up them
not down yeah yeah I know right
free stuff alright save time for mod
number two which this week is Bailey
aches HD dragon replacer pack oh my
goodness it's so majestically floating
around they really do look a lot better
I think the wings is where we've really
noticed there's actually some slightly
slightly translucent to them now up
close is where you stop really noticing
there to fill new textures cuz they're
still they're not like crazy HD it's not
like the weapons were used to when
they're 4k textures are showing but it's
more from a distance I mean generally
you you fight dragons from a distance
and it just makes them look a lot better
so say up here we have an ancient dragon
up close this one's behaving himself not
flying into the ground seems to be doing
quite well so you see they really do
look great don't trust it as maybe most
noticeable Sam I think on the wings we
sweep around the back here slicing some
veins and so what he's done is he's up
the saturation in a lot of them to try
and make them look a little less washed
out and d saturated a bunch of them he
replaced the eyes Tecna you know
textures on the eyes altogether cuz he
said he hated the eyes in those mesh
fixes and texture fixes especially
things on the horns he was saying that
there were issues with those yeah all
the DLC did when it brought in that HD
pack was was just up the resolution and
he didn't make any other fixes so
apparently the ancient dragon one never
got to fix either like at all so he's
invented one for that so lots and lots
of different little tweaks including the
translucency on the wings which is yeah
I think we're and like you were saying
it's whereas no sir
all right SAP time for mod number three
which this week is run for your love you
know that thing when you're in a town
and the dragon comes along and get that
often every little person tries to run
in and might be a hero you're like I'm
the Dragonborn I always try and run and
be here because I am one okay but yeah
exactly
born to be one yeah normally people like
like little if made in loom will leap in
with her I don't know whatever it was a
greatsword she's like well I'm not a
warrior I'll give it a go cuz she's
whole brawler and of course she dies
yeah I'm this mod should make them all
run away oh here come the dragon oh
three of them three of them run you
fools are using it look at him go
they say where do they run let's follow
this guy yeah Tracy this is honor on
alright now he lives in this house and
he is run - oh no I know this is the
this is the bar he's he's run to the
local inn i I want to die drunk ogre
battle born you should be running you
should be running sir he doesn't even
know what to make of it he's already
drunk so it says it says the the guards
and the Companions will stay in fight
okay but everyone else should just run
like crazy and the ones who own homes
should run into their own homes correct
so the ones yeah the ones that own homes
in the attack area will run into them
everyone else will go into the nearest
Inn which will explain the drunken
Huntsman ah right it's not just for
booze but booze can be a part of it if
you want great men over here well is
that her name or carries yeah yes so
she'll get caught up in the crossfire
and you'll accidentally hit with a stray
arrow and then the guards will want to
kill you and it makes it a lot simpler
and in being a hero you actually make a
lot more enemies yeah yeah exactly it's
not what you ever want no no this is
great I mean smells how's the cow oh
yeah I wonder if the cow survived he's
my favorite thing in white runs and he
run did he remember to run did you rot
no he's not running your gate is open
why are you in here
oh the bar yeah we're in the bar you'll
find safety in the Huntsman yeah okay oh
there he goes oh oh he's off he's off
yeah he's like where do I go which way
to the bar
I all I know we've all been there all I
know is my pen really it's more just as
a tidy up immersion mod when you were
just getting desperately frustrated and
people getting in your way we're like
look I know how to kill these things you
don't you've only got a sword most of
them are flying yeah out of my way think
that is impressing me the most is that
the cow is still alive yes how is this I
can quickly fix that yeah okay
no save you're wrong he shouldn't have
to witness these trees he's dead yeah he
was only getting horribly burned it was
a mercy cam he was only gonna become
delicious yes getting overdone
all right it's time from odd number four
I said I'm tired of watching these
dragons fly around and have all the fun
yeah I'm tired of walking all right well
I've got the perfect mod for both of us
keep us both happy for a change it's
burning Skies flyable dragon races three
now two first team Hamish embers Leslie
needed flames let's become a dragon so
when you first install the mod you
should get this power I need to your
powers list now if we come over here we
can see dragon form I just take on the
form of a dragon are you ready
I'm always ready okay flames good start
I say all dragons begin boom we are
definitely a dragon and we just learned
a bunch new of new words of power has
your dragon sorrow - sorrow tor which is
our mighty inferno I like that as
sponsor or Shield of wind improves your
armor rating oh very well
restore health burning wrath but bring
wrath wow that's some good wrath that's
pretty good wrath need to cool down okay
you know should we just do we get to
them we all really want to see let's fly
let's fly whoosh here we are at this one
I am controlling like I'll turn right
way turn left
yeah it almost looked like you could
straight yeah you can't you kind of can
it's better with math and keyboard
though because with the mouse wheel you
can zoom your your view back oh that's
much better and you can see yourself
like yeah right
aha Wow don't get it
I think yeah I think you pulp fiction
perfectly around I tried it's it's more
difficult than you might think
die yes yes ha ha ha ha like a clever
guy he may be running for his life job
there is delicious time yeah that was
tasty that was tasty can you whip with
your tail as well I don't know
yes I can that's that's what rightclick
does that's this BAM this mammoth over
here where are you in the middle there
in the middle area this one yeah that
yet he's on you what how did you what he
was fighting you how did that not kill
you alright you getting Charlie you
gotta Chompy have a lifetime yeah okay
oh there you go yeah I missed that okay
and he was caught in the gravity of my
chair teeth the teeth one is very
effective
yeah Hale one that's not so affect so
much okay oh you can choose your
relationship with other dragons we
should get dragon battles well it's
definitely you fly method if you're to
customize you can choose your species
undead serpentine referent row revered
record I'm a drag with a collar really
let's be an ancient or an elder dragon
perhaps and and also what I really want
to try and doing is that you can you can
make yourself smaller let's become a
mini dragons okay make me a dragon oh
you should cool down a bit no you should
shut up game yeah yeah or I lost smaller
smaller not ridiculously small but you
aren't that look you're almost the same
size the mammoth now yeah I really like
it actually
yes sir it's maybe more he's easier to
get around the place yeah I just find my
new favorite game this row dying deers
from this guy oh good touch get dodge
pal
not for long Phebe and Nordahl is uh
oh yeah God we're so small by comparison
oh man he's much bigger than us and he's
frosty is frosting me serve his frost
breaths are more powerful Bank around
here I've played enough I've what like
Sims I've watched that episode yes haha
yeah she's a proper dragon Ariel
combating alright go back
stop I say don't fly through me oh that
was all that was good
alright LAN oh man you just limit break
tim is he landing is he landing that's
amazing that's awesome
damage in the ground way oh I was so
good wow that's incredible realest lad
this land I think we gotta get it did we
get him - get him always he's still
alive though don't get a bit going oh
I'm stuck oh yeah it's alright Sam I'm
in the gray alright it's only goods fly
quick to fly we need to fly okay yes
please don't break the game yes okay I
hate its pull out use that gun does that
gun come back it's okay
well sad we may have a postmodern before
a bit too hard as we as we start one
over five we can see just the plain
there's littered with dragon corpses and
mammoth corpse seasons it's how it's
like it's been a busy day a busy day but
we couldn't do an episode about the best
dragon mods we're not covering this one
said absolutely not this is arguably the
original it is the one that everybody
knows so yeah this is macho dragons yeah
the one that we've had requested by far
the most yes actually just never shown
it off which is kind of criminal
considering it is like it was one of the
first ones I got everyone like oh my god
Skyrim modern can be ridiculous amazing
so it's time to finally show that off
amazing oh that works I brought in two
of them is that a mistake I love how
they do many wings there it is so so
that is meant to be Macho Man Randy
Savage immortalized forever in dragon
form so uh I guess can we take a look at
him yeah we can occasion terrifying long
hands shall we toggle free camera and
drop flight there with him yeah no I'm
gonna get you matcha Man Randy Savage
Dragon God he's fast he is fast well I
mean you know he's a he's Randy Savage
professional the madness oh come on come
on it's at me here is yeah oh no I think
we're about to die stab God what's the
only way
Kevin Van Lord could ever be defeated
mold by match him no God it's one of the
only times he's ever died oh but what a
way to go that's the way he wanted to go
I remember him saying don't worry he's
back look at himself he's wonderful it
makes it easier for him to go to do as
years that's where the resonance comes
from it's all jaw
it was about time then Macho Man Randy
Savage met some chickens then what we
are gonna have to do is I love how they
filed up but respect yeah like we're
here for you it's a memorial thing
self-preservation so let's say let's
let's set one of them off as like a fuse
yeah are we gonna fly with him or are we
gonna watch from a distance oh wow we're
getting with him because her flight was
I didn't think that was gonna work I
thought they were minted dead like
heroes nope
why doesn't happen anymore Harley Wow
that was quite the unexpected flight
when you've got Macho Man Randy Savage
there he doesn't wait for anything I
bring it we just landed on a dear oh
dear oh dear oh dear oh dear
you didn't even mean that I love thanks
to the AI he's just he's not going
anywhere
he's got he's got better things well
said that was just five and a few other
is kind of thrown in there yeah of the
best dragon was the ones that we think
you kind of give you the best dragon
experience faster than of course much of
Man Randy Savage himself had to be there
and that of course as modern number five
he did take place of our usual user
voted yes so we're gonna be knocking
that one back for another week so it's
over all over that's what they say on TV
when they decided the last minute to
change something so it's a roll guys
let's turn this error into something
that sounds great so there you go yeah
five dragon mods in fact technically six
but yeah you know we have featured other
dragon mods during this series yeah we
didn't want to like show all the best
ones again once you're already showing
so for example if you want other ones
that we can highly recommend is really
useful dragons which is the almost the
Tank Engine yeah those guys were kissing
we were gonna make this top five oh yes
nods top 5 scary Menards of the week of
the ways so nod number one is really
useful dragons which is the Thomas the
Tank Engine one number two could be my
little pony one we did as well the
replacer that was pretty gray it was
terrifying but yeah great yeah
nod number three goes to one that we
showed at first yes conjunction dragons
yes this dragon combat overhaul that was
great that is a must it means does
require you to spend a lot of time on
the floor when you
bashed around yeah but it's pretty great
if you want to watch that one in it's
full it's the one I recorded with Jess
over yeah oh is right yeah it was the
first episode of this year advert and
then we also have the loyal voiced
dragon and human follower farlow we
tried to get follow car to work and he
kind of did but as soon as he entered
combat begin to crash yes we turned off
all other dragon mods and then it didn't
seem to fix it so we've made a mistake
there somewhere I think other people
seem to love that mod so check that one
up too if you want to get smaller who's
both a human and on command can turn
into a dragon
hee hee the bits that we had him working
he was phantom voice yet that's great so
we just had as soon as he took off
ah crash and you can choose to have them
in blue or red or we could have was a
crash but here we go
so those were the extra mods that we
didn't showcase but that are totally
totally worth checking out you're on the
full ultimate dragon experience Seb yes
so for question this is time for
comments from you guys have several well
the best ones so I'll return back last
week we all seem to think that we were
dead oh no all the show was dead oh we
got a comment from Alex white saying I
feel like this show is on borrowed time
and I'm scared I want it to last forever
worry not Alex it is not on borrowed
time we're here we simply had to take
our two-week break we did we did well we
have her at e3 and then we had other
things to do so but yes thank you show
is not dead it's not dead no yeah night
King says um I think they need to add an
unarmed skill in the next Elder Scrolls
and overhaul the magic system though
this was in response to what we were
saying we would like to see in the next
cell oh yes so we were yes very in
reference soon and then how it can make
modding better no I like how they follow
up comments who's this from they had a
good point so fists of the outcast okay
says so oblivion slash moral wind style
gameplay with better graphics and
animation yeah so there is definitely
that kind of more hardcore or
traditionalist Elder Scrolls player who
likes the kind of the
and the way magic the way the magic
system worked from the older games yeah
I much prefer it in Skyrim to be honest
I think it's the best it's been I really
like it in sky as well that actually we
had a follow-up one about the combat
someone say real Scallon said I think
the Elder Scrolls with the combat system
of chivalry would be amazing yeah
chivalry is yeah
chivalry combats great but then it's
difficult cause rod Corps you're
fighting other people whereas obviously
it's NPCs it's AI so it's been different
so I know it's very very detailed style
combat pressures in combat is just
difficult to do that's still
third-person
can be there yeah yeah and then we also
have metal all day all night great name
for the next Elder Scrolls I'd like to
see drop in coop jump into your buddies
game quickly create a standard can help
him with his quays or mess around why
not if you do in Far Cry new Far Cry 4
each oh dear in Elder Scrolls 6 that
would be okay we are we go on
I'm machine says I think you two don't
make if you two don't make an appearance
in the next Elder Scrolls game sorry I
feel that they'll have missed out on an
opportunity to thank you guys for
keeping their game in the media spot
some reason I agree wholeheartedly on
this what's strange I also a greatly I
could be the main character that'd be
great wouldn't it yes and I can be his
loyal sidekick who always gets slightly
ignored in the introduction I've
rectified their problems here we've been
through this we've been through this
well those were the the bits of comment
and feedback very good from last week so
thank you very much guys great to always
hear what you think and to kind of join
in those conversations that we have and
then we get your opinion like a weak
layer is really great it's been great
and if you want to call it another thing
that we've brought up any of these
dragon mods or anything like that the
best way to do so is to get in touch
over Twitter I'm at Camp frass Rob he's
at ready sir be go or you can use the
hashtag gears Skyrim we will always read
them or you can just chuck them in the
comments box and we look at the comments
on YouTube and GameSpot absolutely there
are always loads on YouTube which is
great and that's where my questions came
from today yeah exactly we often take
them for
Twitter so it was nice to mix things up
a little bit yeah now as we said the mod
vote has been rolled back to next week
yes if you want to vote you can still
running it alive
it's a tiny real calm force let forward
slash ready seve blog ready Sebby blog
it's being kind of run away with at the
moment which one that's charging at the
lead that would be a become the Ala
virus there's something on 84% oh wow so
you can change it though guys got
together you could go in there still all
to play for but at the moment it's kind
of looking like we're gonna go with that
one no choice it out of our hands
I mean we could fix it we won't but we
totally kid but we won't we might
probably what we'll see so sad when all
these lovely viewers are done watching
this yeah and they can't wait till next
week icon well yeah well what would we
suggest they watch well I'm gonna go
with two shows this week I'm gonna go
with that show that you make because you
know you know it's kind of all reality
it's watchable it's watch it won't wash
that yes I would say the world cups on
right now oh yeah apparently unless
you're watching this way in the future
well you're late yes you go on you have
the world cups on England's out but a
lot of you folks don't seem to know much
about soccer it seems when I say you
folks I mean us gamers as gamers all of
us so Danny has taken to the internet
with his episode of the point which
explains all about soccer and it's
football and brilliant it is hilarious
star is the wonderful Rob handler II who
is a great great funny man gonna
describe great funny right funny man as
you can see we're the pro writers here
yeah
great the funny man funny man is it
funny men's think it's funny many men's
we just go and watch the point anyway
yes really excellent and that will you
know just help fill that little gap
until there's more Skyrim money
absolutely what are you doing for
reality check this week Cameron oh well
the one that's already live you can
watch her in there's all but weaponizing
animals which we are very good and I'm
gonna be doing one all about the science
of the The Witcher yeah very very
similar to scar a lovely fantasy RPG
beautifully well definitely check those
out as well but make sure you come back
here next week for more top 5 scare and
mods of the week
[Music]
you